My name is Sharon Katzki. I am the founder and president of his and light. I am also a passionate
LED light therapist with over 20 years of experience in the field of light therapy. My goal is to
provide people and animals a safe, non-invasive, painless method to promote healing using the body's
own immune system response. Countless medical practitioners, chiropractors, veterinarians,
and people at home have found tremendous benefits for themselves and their patients with the vision
light. I'd like to show you how and why this therapy is so remarkably effective. Tell me if
this is you right now. You're stuck at home, and not because of the coronavirus, but because
it's physically painful for you to do outdoor activities that you used to love. Activities like jogging,
playing golf, biking, horseback riding, playing with your kids, or even taking a walk in your
neighborhood. You see your friends posting photos, having fun on the golf course or hiking with
their family, and you wish you could do that too. But as much as you want to, that injury of yours
hasn't fully healed, and the pain is keeping you from getting out there and enjoying life. Or maybe
it's arthritis stiffening your joints and making the smallest activities a real chore. Wouldn't it
be nice to be able to move freely and feel energized? Wouldn't you love to take part in outdoor activities
again? Imagine all the fun you can have with your family and friends now that you're no longer in
pain from your injury or arthritis. The question remains, how can you relieve your pain and accelerate
healing in a way that's safe, effective, pain-free, and drug-free? Recent advances in photo
biomodulation therapy hold the answer. Also known as PBMT or Light Therapy, this clinically proven
treatment method is remarkably effective at treating a wide spectrum of health issues, including reducing
chronic inflammation, easing acute and chronic pain, increasing circulation, improving lymphatic
drainage, accelerating natural healing, stimulating cellular repair, and many other benefits. While
additional research, development, and clinical trials continue across a broad spectrum of diseases,
conditions, and symptoms, the list of publications to date typically shows a theory of tremendous
promise and far-reaching implication, making PBMT an exciting addition to existing therapies.
This has led to numerous handheld light therapy devices on the market right now. However,
most of these only provide a single color and a single setting, which severely limits their
functionality. As a satisfied long-term user of lights for healing, I felt there was a need to
offer one device, a one price that offers multiple colors, power settings, and functionalities,
all of which can easily be operated by anyone. This led me to create the patent-pending
vision light. I wanted an all-in-one user-friendly operator-controlled light therapy device
that provides comprehensive healing benefits and won't become obsolete in a few years.
I made sure that the vision light is portable and handy without sacrificing any of its robust
features. One of our customers has called it a doctor in a box due to its convenient portability
and that you can take it with you wherever you go. We have not found another light therapy tool
that provides the comprehensive healing options and features that the vision light has,
which is why our unique technology is now patent-pending. You don't need to worry about harmful
EMFs unlike plug-in devices because the vision light doesn't produce any EMFs.
Now here's a brief breakdown of the four primary color buttons
the vision light provides. Red is used to reduce pain and inflammation, increase circulation,
stimulate cellular repair, and accelerate the healing of wounds, cuts, and scars.
It's also used to trigger acupunct, which is a key aspect of acupuncture.
Blue light is soothing as well as antibacterial and antifungal, which is great for combating fever
and infection. It acts like ice, so we like to call it ice in a light. Green light balances the
mind and body, reducing the effects of migraines, stress, anxiety, and sleeplessness.
There is a lot of current research taking place on green light, showing that green is the new red.
Near infrared light is not visible to the eye and has deeper penetration for acute and chronic
pain management. This is what you'll use to alleviate pain from injuries, arthritis, and
swarm muscles. That is just four of the eight PBMT colors that you can use with your new vision light.
Because the vision light is polychromatic light, you can also blend the colors, giving you magenta,
yellow, turquoise, and white, providing a range of additional healing benefits. We've had many
positive success stories from our customers and clients. Take a look at just a couple of them.
So the vision light is not just a light that switches color. It is a polychromatic variable pulse
hand held medical device used by medical practitioners, chiropractors, physical therapists,
and veterinarians for treating their patients. However, it is also designed for easy use by anyone
and no medical degree is required. Now from time to time we may offer sales on the website
and we usually announce them in a newsletter. These sales will come and go without notice.
So be sure to stay updated by signing up for our newsletter or following us on Facebook.
Many individuals as well as animal patients have benefited from the comprehensive healing that the
vision light provides. If you want to learn how the vision light and light therapy can help with your
unique health issue, our website, visionlight.com offers a wealth of information on the vision light's
features, functionalities, and links to trial-backed evidence. Or you can order your patent-pending
vision light at this link. Thank you for watching. I'm Sharon and I appreciate your time and I wish
you light, health, and happiness.